reden wir mal über die gastrobranche die
leiden in diesen tagen natürlich
besonders unter corona die ganze
gastrobranche nein alles was geliefert
wird läuft natürlich super aber wer
liefert eigentlich bei uns in
deutschland
das war mal wissen sie ein total
umkämpfter markt
da gab es für dora lieferheld pizza.de
ich möchte sagen regelrechten wettbewerb
bis da lieferando 2009 10 nach und nach
alle andern aufgefuttert gesundheit und
glückwunsch zum quasi monopol lieferando
gehört zum niederländischen konzern
justy texaid und hat seinen umsatz bei
uns allein im ersten halbjahr 2020 mal
eben verdoppelt
auf über 160 millionen natürlich super
für die lieferando lieferer die doch
bestimmt am gewinn beteiligt sind
okay das nicht aber dafür dürfen die
hatten sich fest ihr eigenes fahrrad
benutzen und kriegen den verschleiß auch
noch bezahlt lieferando zeit seinen
fahrern auch reiter genannt nur eine
verschleiß pauschale 10 cent pro
kilometer
gedeckelt auf maximal 44 euro pro monat
und das in form eines amazon gutschein
jetzt müssen wir nur noch die paketboten
mit lieferando gutschein bezahlen und
dann haben wir den perfekten circle auf
ausbeutung das geschäft von lieferando
brummt wie hulle pandemie bedingt
natürlich was willst du machen selber
kochen meine klar für die umwelt eher
schlecht aber irgendwas ist halt immer
lieferando ist jedenfalls stolz weil
ihre über 5000 rider
sozialversicherungspflichtig angestellt
sind leider sehr oft befristet und viele
davon auf 450 euro basis brad hat den
job wirklich aber mit 1000
das problem bei der pausenregelung ist
eigentlich dass die pausen zu lange
gesetzt werden und dass die fahrer keine
räume haben wo sie sich momentan
aufhalten können dass es natürlich
corona geschuldet aber trotzdem müssen
die fahrer dann einfach zwei stunden
oder anderthalb stunden pause draußen
machen ja und man kann sich doch in
seine wahl halte box setzen und dann bei
lieferanten heißen tee bestellen
leider kriegen 10 50 die stunde plus
bonus wenn man ganz viel radelt und sehr
schnell radelt no risk no bonus und bei
der motivation hilft eine app die sich
alle rider auf ihr privates handy laden
müssen
pflicht denn da wird die arbeit
sekundengenau getrackt pausen
schnelligkeit unnötige toilettenzeiten
so erstellt der lieferdienste ein
präzises leistungs und verhaltens profil
für jeden einzelnen rider wirklich
irgend was die app kann ja die app hat
verschiedene berechtigungen unter
anderem kann sie auf meinen standort gps
basiert zu greifen dann kann die app
audio aufnehmen das auch eine frage
wofür eigentlich
dann den inhalt meiner speicherkarte
ändern oder löschen
die app kann sogar mit seiner freundin
schluss machen schreibt dann sorry der
markt hat keine zeit mehr für dich der
muss essen ausfahren
das was erlaubt ist und wenn sie zu
hause jetzt sagen haben die rider denn
keinen betriebsrat
doch klar auch betriebsrat mit t das
schwierig ist schwierig lieferando
versucht wohl betriebsrats gründungen so
schwer wie irgend möglich zu machen
in frankfurt zum beispiel mussten die
mitarbeiter listen die man für so was
braucht über zwei instanzen eingeklagt
werden aber nicht nur die reiter sind
von lieferando abhängig sondern im
corona zeiten auch die restaurants
es bleibt ja nix außer liefergeschäft
bei jeder bestellung kassiert der
konzern 13 prozent nur für die nutzung
der plattform und sogar 30 prozent wenn
lieferando ausliefert das ist ja fast
eine schleichende übernahme einer ganzen
branche
jeder auftrag zählt doch manchmal ist
die nachfrage in seinem viertel so hoch
dass die fahrer im umkreis ausgelastet
sind
dann nimmt lieferando seinen laden
einfach aus der app
was bringt mir das ich will immer nur
ich ich ich ja wenn lieferando mal nicht
liefern kann
sperren sie online seinen laden zu es
kein einzelfall
obendrein schaltet der konzern aber auch
noch sogenannte schatten webseiten und
da wird es richtig lustig schatten
webseiten wie so aussehen wie die
originalseite des restaurants rund
50.000 gibt schon davon in deutschland
ede zimmermann hätte damals gesagt
vorsicht falle bzw
fahr falle ist legal aber unverschämt
der kunde denkt er bestellt direkt bei
seinem lieblingsitaliener tut er aber
gar nicht und durch einen deal mit
google stehen diese schattenseiten von
denen auch noch ganz oben
hier allerdings hätte man die fälschung
erkennen können denn bei dieser
folgenden lieferando schatten webseite
für einen wohlgemerkt veganes restaurant
gibt es einen hinweis dass etwas nicht
stimmt wenn man genau hinguckt ja der
erste vegane laden bei dem ich was
bestellen würde dieses nachbauen von
seiten ist leider erlaubt wenn die
restaurantbesitzer nicht ausdrücklich
den agbs widersprechen wenn es doch für
uns kunden nun eine möglichkeit gäbe
essen ohne umwege beim restaurant zu
ordern
ach gibts herzlich willkommen zu die
heute show erklärt wie man bei seinem
lieblingsrestaurant gestellt ohne den
gierigen lieferando säcken geld in den
rachen zu werfen da es ist es ist
zugegebenermaßen nicht einfach aber es
ist machbar
ich kann zum beispiel das restaurant
googeln aber und jetzt kommt der clou
den ersten treffer ignorieren denn das
ist lieferando dafür gucke ich weiter
oben nach der sogenannten kelle phone
number ja damit rufe ich im restaurant
an und bestelle analog per sprache
schwer zu erklären also im prinzip muss
ich die sachen die ich sonst in der app
an tippe vorlesen
falls ihnen das komisch vorkommt einem
anderen menschen etwas vorzulesen
stellen sie einfach vor sie reden mit
siri oder alexa aber selbst dafür sind
viele von uns einfach zu faul ist
lieferando die alte kranke wächst also
weiter und weiter und sucht ständig nach
90 weida
da ist auch wenn keiner von den coolen
sein dann wird jetzt liefern lowrider
oder madrid und das tollste ist so darf
sein eigenes rad benutzen musste
dringend mal etwas von deinem geld rider
der wahnsinn was dieser biker gang alles
erlebt
[Musik]
ja
kaluza mach mit bei den gewinnern
bald wird er locker und verschärft dann
gehen noch mehr restaurants breite und
irgendwann wird nur noch ausgeliefert
man wird ganz deutschland beliefert und
irgendwann ganz europa und zwar so wie
noch nie zuvor ein europa beliefert
was bewirkt dich jetzt mit unserer scoop
helfen dir dein potenzial voll
auszuschöpfen
ich sehe hier rund um die uhr um eine
rider gerade lang rein
junge du stehst warum stehst du trot na
ja ich sag mal so wir haben also die
pizza davon
[Musik]
du bist seit sieben stunden aktiv was
ist da los bist du gestorben oder was im
schlaf
na ja super musst du wissen aber für die
performance ist das so ronny wegen einer
vertragsverlängerung ich sehe letzten
mittwoch gab es eine klausel dass sind
40 sekunden gefinkelte sondern im grünen
bereich und dann aber noch 12 sekunden
abgeschüttelt abschütteln was kommt als
nächstes händewaschen es sind schwere
zeiten aber gemeinsam kommen wir dadurch
frühestens ende märz wieder
außengastronomie vielleicht wir müssen
sich die gastronomen bei dieser meldung
gefühlt haben keine ahnung ich kann
ihnen nur sagen wie ich mich gefühlt
habe
[Musik]
lieferando man kann gar nicht soviel
bestellen wie man kotzen möchte
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und 70 -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]